[Music]
human beings are natural storytellers
the purpose of storytelling is to
connect
us together
i storytell as an actor a director as a
writer as a
producer as a public speaker
storytelling is one of the primary
building blocks of civilization
everything that is important to us as a
species
has been contained in stories
in this master class i'm going to help
you identify
your personal story at home
at work in play helping make you
a more effective communicator
i'm going to touch on storytelling for
children storytelling for adults
and public speaking i'm nervous every
time i speak in public
i'm going to say that again i've been
doing this for 45 years
every time i open my mouth
in public i'm nervous there is a phrase
that i love using
fear is simply suppressed excitement
we all have nervousness and suppressed
excitement
is a lot easier to deal with
intellectually than our fear
this storm will pass soon said papa
would you like me to read you a story
i know just the one to help you feel
better
when i was a kid you were either going
to
read a book in my mother's home or you
were going to get hit with one
it was your choice but you were going to
have
an experience with the written word i
come from a family of teachers of
educators
so it's my turn
storytelling is a gateway to our
imagination
we can't have a just
equitable society unless we can imagine
one
we are here to contribute
something mighty and our storytelling
is the ship that we sail on i'm levar
burton
and this is my master class
[Music]
you